أين هو الآن
مع تعثر الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا،
هناك مجموعة واحدة تحقق بعض
النجاح في ساحة المعركة، وهي شركة فاغنر
العسكرية الخاصة ذات الفعالية الوحشية
بقيادة بوتين حليف يفداني بريغوسيان،
متأكد من
سبب فعاليتنا ومن أين تأتي هذه
الفعالية ويسأل أولاً لقد
كنا
من المحتمل أننا الجيش الأكثر خبرة
في العالم اليوم، ونحن نقاتل لسنوات عديدة، وتشعر
القيادة الأوكرانية بالقلق من
نجاح فاغنر. وقد حصلت CNN حصريًا على
وثيقة عسكرية تحدد
تقييم كييف للجماعة، وهناك أيضًا
أسباب عسكرية بحتة
لفعالية فاغنر، كما تقول الوثيقة.
هيكل القيادة والتكتيكات
المستخدمة حاليًا هي الوحيدة
الفعالة للقوات المعبأة سيئة التدريب
والتي تشكل
غالبية القوات البرية الروسية. قام
الجيش الأوكراني بتصوير هذا الفيديو الذي
يظهر تكتيكات فاغنر الهجومية باستخدام
موجات من المقاتلين الذين يحاولون التغلب على
الموقع الأوكراني وتطويقه  من
المقرر أن تكون المهام بدائية قدر
الإمكان لتحقيق الهدف، حيث
يتم نشر العديد من المجموعات الهجومية
ويمكن تنفيذ الهجمات لفترة طويلة من
الزمن دون النظر إلى الخسائر، كما تقول الوثيقة، إن
الموجات الأولى غالبًا ما تكون من المدانين الذين
يتم استخدامهم أساسًا كمدافع
للقتلى.  الآلاف من جنود فاغنر
لا يهم المجتمع الروسي،
الوثيقة العسكرية تؤكد أن
الانسحاب غير المصرح به للفريق أو
دون الإصابة يعاقب عليه بالإعدام
على الفور،
ولا يخفي الأجنبي حقيقة أن
الخسائر لا تهم بالنسبة له، فقد
زارها مؤخرًا  قال إن المبنى الذي
تم الاحتفاظ فيه بجثث الذين سقطوا،
انتهت عقودهم إنهم عائدون إلى
ديارهم، لكنه نسي أيضًا
ادعاءات احترام الأوكرانيين الذين
يدافعون ضد مرتزقته قائلين
إنهم يقاتلون ببسالة،
ويجب أن تكون أكثر حرصًا لإرسالهم
بطريقة كريمة قالها أثناء إشرافه
مؤخرًا على تبادل
الجثث بين فاغنر والجيش الأوكراني
داخليًا على الرغم من أنه نظام وحشي،
نشرت قناة مؤيدة لفاغنر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مؤخرًا مقطع فيديو لمرتزقة يستخدمون
مطرقة ثقيلة لقتل رفيق سابق
يُزعم أنه انشق وانتقد
المجموعة نشرت الكلمة في
Battlefield 2، اعترضت المخابرات الأوكرانية
هذه المكالمة التي لم تتمكن CNN من
التحقق بشكل مستقل من
جندي روسي يتحدث إلى صديق
أجنبي. لا
تزال معنويات فاغنر تبدو عالية كما
يقول الأوكرانيون، وغالبًا ما يكون المقاتلون
أفضل تجهيزًا من
القوات النظامية الروسية بفضل ما
يدعي الأوكرانيون أن التكنولوجيا من صنع الولايات المتحدة
على عكس
وسائل الاتصال الرئيسية للقوات المسلحة الروسية. إن وسائل الاتصال الرئيسية لشركة فاغنر هي
محطات البث الإذاعي أمريكية الصنع
وأجهزة اتصال لاسلكية من موتورولا.
تقول الوثيقة الأوكرانية. الآن تواصلت CNN مع
موتورولا للحصول على بيان، وسوف  قال
إنه بعد وقت قصير من غزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا، أوقفوا جميع
مبيعاتهم لكل من روسيا وبيلاروسيا
وأغلقوا عملياتهم هناك، وفي الوقت نفسه،
هناك الكثير من
الأشياء الرائعة في تلك الوثائق من الجيش الأوكراني، على سبيل المثال،
يقول الأوكرانيون إنه على الرغم من
الاقتتال الداخلي،  كما ترى بين
وزارة الدفاع الروسية وشركة فاغنر على
وجه التحديد،
يبدو أن الجيش الروسي يوصي الآن ببعض
تكتيكات الهجوم الوحشي من فاغنر
للقوات النظامية الروسية وكذلك لمحطة سي إن إن
كييف